en milieu d'après-midi la vingtaine
d'enquêteurs ranger leur matériel et
quitte les lieux
les fouilles d'un ancien jardin du beau
père de michel fourniret se termine et
n'ont rien donné pendant deux jours
policiers gendarmes et experts
scientifiques ont cherché en vain donc
le corps de marie angèle domèce une
icaunaise handicapées mentales disparu
en 1988 alors âgé de 19 ans et dont
michel fourniret avait avoué le meurtre
il ya quelques mois pour les besoins de
l'instruction
le tueur en série est revenue
physiquement dans ce jardin
mercredi dernier deux jours plus tôt il
y est même resté plusieurs heures avec
les enquêteurs
mais ces indications trop vague son
manque de coopération n'ont pas permis
de faire avancer les investigations
seule certitude selon une source proche
de l'enquêté
marie-angèle domèce n'est pas enterré
dans ce jardin de saint cyr les cowboys
la justice pourrait clore son
instruction avant la fin de l'année
michel fourniret pourrait être jugé pour
ce meurtre cours en 2020 actuellement en
prison
le tueur en série a déjà été condamné
pour cet autre meurtre à la perpétuité
incompressible